I want to start with a huge congrats on
the series I've seen the first four
episodes and they're fantastic I'm so
curious um there is well I have a lot of
things but I think what I love the most
is that there's no Skywalkers Jedis
desert planets
um lightsabers it's it's focusing on a
completely different place in the Star
Wars Universe uh can you sort of talk
about that aspect well that's
um Tony Gilroy's vision and his writing
and where he at the moment in time that
he's chosen to set this
is at the heart of what you're talking
about
we know Tony's writing he comes from you
know for he's written the Bourne films
he wrote Michael Clayton we know that he
writes
so beautifully and intricately and
deftly the Spy genre
and
um that's the world where in investing
in in with Andor this kind of spy
Thriller
um corner of the Star Wars world
but at the time we meet them is a time I
don't think we've really discovered much
or or or
wrestle with much within the um the
timeline of Star Wars and that is where
there is not quite a rebellion yet you
know we're so used to having the Empire
versus Rebellion
we have a very uh a burgeoning
um
Whisper of rebellion in this but they
are not connected in any way there is no
Central Force they are so disparate
there is there is an understanding that
there is an oppressive regime that um
Palpatine is is marching forward on that
road to autocracy that we recognize
but there is no Collective Rebellion at
this stage
so
were it's a bit murkier we're we're
playing in a world where it's less black
and white where characters have to
really Wade within gray areas in order
to reach each other from what I
understand your character has had a lot
of stuff in like the Star Wars novels a
lot of things have happened have you
read any of that and has Tony
Incorporated any of the book stuff into
the series do you know uh I haven't read
the novels I have been a part of this
for a while and I certainly have played
her at different moments but I don't
know the novels and I'm not sure what
Tony has excavated for Source material
um yeah so I can't help you there it's
totally cool so you have a great scene
with stellen uh and I'm not going to
give anything away but there's it's just
it's very well done can you sort of talk
about working with him as a scene
partner and because it's such a grounded
it's just a very well done you know it's
very well done I I think you're talking
about the scene where we first meet
Monmouth in this series and we meet her
at Lutheran's gallery now
um
stellen Skarsgard plays Lutheran who's
quite an enigmatic character in this
um and he's he is he has many faces
and she meets him and it feels at once
familiar but also
is quite public we meet a senator and we
know her as a senator with a gallery
owner
what's extraordinary is that Within
half a scene
we pull back the layers and they enter a
private space and we see
a different version of the relationship
between these two people so straight
away it's multifaceted so the joy of
that as an actor to play to have to be
able to play within a scene the public
and the private and to do it together
with such taught
dialogue it was like it was like Sword
Play we had we had so much fun together
um he's an extraordinary actor and he's
he's a delightful human being and we we
were like kids in a playground on that
set you also would appreciate
that set is so beautiful
the architecture of Luke Hall's design
is stunning and I hope it's as stunning
for viewers as it is was it is and was
for us to play in it it is so tactile
everything in that Gallery space
was a piece of art and
when you look at it you can see not just
the Artistry of uh Luke and the um
crafts people but you can see the
history of the different cultures and
the different timelines that inhabit all
these planets on Star Wars it tells such
an amazing story in one space so stellen
and I had a ball
you might even see a Mandalorian armor
on on one of the tables anyway I gotta
go I'm just gonna say congrats on the
series I've loved it so far can't wait
to see the rest thank you for your time